in the midst of all of what is going on
uh including with the coveted spikes and
so many other things
which we will talk about today president
joe biden's approval
is soaring among independents it is
remaining high among democrats
it is remaining low among republicans
but it is increasing
dramatically among independents and also
specifically on the issue of covet
handling
which now donald trump himself and many
republicans are actively antagonizing
the biden administration over
which we will also talk about today joe
biden getting as donald trump likes to
say
very high marks when it comes to um
the handling of the pandemic so let's
look
at a couple of articles about these
polls first of all
newsweek joe biden's approval rating
soaring among independents
joe biden's approval rating among
independents has soared following a
sharp decline at the end of june
according to an
ipsos survey the ipsos weekly approval
tracker
found that biden's rating among
independents stood at 52
in the latest survey the president's
overall approval rating is 53
disapproval is 42. biden enjoys
88 approval among democrats that's very
close to the
to within the margin of error down from
91 that's down three points but the
margin of error is three and a half
approval among republicans is uh up very
slightly
13 to 17 but the approval figure from
independent voters is up sharply
it hit uh the last time biden's approval
among independents
hit 50 percent was june 17th
he was down to 45 percent then he was
down to
34 among independents at the beginning
of july that's the lowest in the survey
since biden took office
and then it recovered to 44 and now to
52
why the president enjoys high approval
from independence on
covid pandemic with 59 approval
which is in line with his overall
approval
that is a very very good sign opinions
on the president's performance follow
party lines
86 percent of democrats approve on his
covet approach
compared to just 33 percent of
republicans but i will tell you
33 approval on covet from republicans
when they are the the
uh kovit is being used as a weapon
against joe biden
by republicans to say we can't trust the
vaccines which trump is now saying we
will get to that
um uh the too authoritarian when it
comes to masking or vaccines or whatever
the case
to still have one in three republicans
support you when disinformation is this
weaponized i actually think is
still notable in some sense
let's look at more data here biden gets
66 approval from americans in pandemic
handling
this is from a cbs news yougov poll
26 of americans believe biden is doing a
very good job at managing the pandemic
but another 40 percent
think he's doing a somewhat good job
only 34 disapprove of biden's covet
handling
only 18 call it very bad people said the
country as a whole
is doing a better job now at getting the
covid
the coronavirus under control than what
was going on in january
polling from january and july
flip-flopped
64 percent now believe the pandemic is
going well
only 35 believed that it was going well
back in january so there's a few
different
takeaways here and important things
first of all
um when you go to republicans and you
say well what
how do you explain this it seems even
through your propaganda joe biden is
doing well
particularly on this many of them will
say have you seen joe biden's youtube
live streams
and have you seen the down votes there's
often you know like
200 likes and 3 000 dislikes when joe
biden live streams
it is of no meaning or value at all
this is what republicans are doing they
what they call
they call it brigading or ratioing joe
biden's live streams and they dislike
them
it's not even a serious part of the
conversation but that's what they will
say
part of the reason that joe biden's
approval
isn't higher is that it has been a
right-wing media
concerted effort since joe biden was
sworn in
to simply assassinate character and make
wild allegations
about joe biden being a marxist
communist dictatorial authoritarian
right-wing media used to be 85 percent
about character assassination and lies
it's now 99 about character
assassination and lies it's been a
desperate race to see
who can come up with the most outrageous
lie about the quote democrat party
and socialist biden in part maybe
because of the vacuum created by the
death of rush limbaugh among right-wing
media now i do think there are some
independents
who maybe thought the lies about joe
biden were true
maybe joe biden was going to take their
guns maybe joe biden was going to force
them to be vegan maybe joe biden was
going to force them to
you know i don't know uh flush toilets
10 or 15 times
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times
right and it's not happening and some of
those independents are actually saying
oh you know what
maybe maybe that was crazy and i never
should have believed that and joe
biden's actually doing okay as far as
republicans are
go many of them are too far gone and too
indoctrinated to change their views but
there seem to be independents that can
see reason
and they're coming over to say i approve
of joe biden and i approve of joe
biden's handling of some issues
now the implications here are twofold
the immediate implications continue to
be
what is the impact on people simply
getting vaccinated because we're having
trouble vaccinating our way out of the
out of the pandemic because of half of
republicans who don't want to get that
vaccine that's the immediate question
in terms of electorally i think it's too
early to take this information
about biden's approval and say anything
about 2024
we don't even know if joe biden is
running in 2024. it's just too early it
doesn't tell us anything
but we are starting to be able to glean
some things about 2022. typically in
2022
based on history as we talked with
rachel bittikoffer almost exclusively
you would expect democrats to do poorly
in the house
maybe in the senate that's the way it
tends to go
party takes the white house two years
later they do poorly in the midterms
however it may not be that way if joe
biden continues to have
what is his you know in the modern
historical context a high approval
rating
republicans really need swing voters to
do well in 2022
the fact that independents are the group
that is most heavily shifting
from being against joe biden to being in
favor of him approving of him
that's not a particularly good sign for
republicans now their answer
might be let's just suppress even more
of the vote and they're trying to do
that
by proposing more than 250 voter
suppression bills across 40 something
states so
we are starting to be able to talk about
2022
but still a long way to go before i
would be comfortable saying
i think it'll probably be okay for
democrats or it could be a bloodbath for
democrats we don't know yet
we will have a clearer picture i think
as we close in
on september where the 2022 races are
expected to start getting going early
and
speaking of by september mid-august
august 16th listen to this it's the
david pakman show
16th anniversary 16th anniversary
august 16th we are going to be doing a
one-day membership
blowout on that day i really hope that
if you've enjoyed the show
or even if you don't but you you think
there's some value in it existing you
can dislike me but
maybe you think the show has some value
some redeeming quality
some redemptive quality please get on my
newsletter at davidpakman.com because on
august 16th you'll get an email telling
you
how to take advantage of a one day
outrageous
outrageous membership special we'll take
a quick break
send me your thoughts about independence
shifting to biden
on twitter where you can find me at
deepakman